this next story is sort of funny because
it's actually something that
uh uh people donald trump has stumbled
upon
threatening to do something that many of
us on the left would be very interested
in seeing him do to some degree
donald trump is now threatening to
defund the entire military
if he's not allowed to punish the
internet for being mean to him this is
the epitome of the triggered
snowflake child that is thin-skinned
donald trump
so here's what happened back when donald
trump threw that bizarre temper tantrum
last week on thanksgiving day
against a reporter where he said don't
talk to me that way this is the i'm the
president utah you respect me
the hashtag diaperdon started trending
on twitter
trump was furious about it and believed
that twitter should be blocking the
hashtag stopping the hashtag
whatever so then trump went on twitter
and said
that unless section 230 is terminated
as part of the new funding of the
military ndaa
he will veto the entire defense funding
bill trump tweeted quote section 230
which is a liability shielding gift from
the u.s to big tech
is a serious threat to our national
security and election integrity
our country can never be safe and secure
if we allow that to stand
therefore if the very dangerous and
unfair section 230 is not completely
terminated as part of the ndaa
i will be forced to unequivocally veto
the bill when sent to the very beautiful
resolute desk
take back america now thank you so this
does require some explanation to
understand
the connection like what is the
connection between that and mean tweets
about trump
and it really requires sort of
stretching your imagination to
understand
donald trump thinks that the reason
twitter allowed
the hashtag diaperdon to trend is that
twitter
is shielded from liability for the
things on its platform
by section 230. so the idea is
if you terminate section 230 twitter
would then be liable for the content on
its platform
rather than the users being liable and
so twitter would say oh if we're liable
we're going to shut down the diaper don
but of course this is
very very stupid because first of all
why would twitter have liability because
diaper don
is trending like in other words even if
you repeal section 230
and twitter is now theoretically liable
for the content on their platform
what is the liability with diaper don
trending like
it's just a hashtag trump is a public
person a very powerful public person
there are there would be no
repercussions for that
and secondly the hilarity is that if
indeed section 230 was terminated
twitter would probably have to ban trump
because it's trump that regularly
publishes things to twitter
that would endanger twitter trump threat
threatens people
on twitter trump incites his followers
to bully people as we've seen happen
with
georgia election workers over the last
week so the incredible irony
is that donald trump seems to think if
section 230 goes away
twitter will block diaper don but more
likely
if section 230 goes away twitter has to
ban trump
but then we get to the really outrageous
part which is that trump ran
on the biggest and best military ever
and he claimed obama ruined the military
and obama
uh hurt and diminished the military
and his followers love the military and
on a whim
trump says if we don't make it so
twitter will block diaper done
i will defund the entire military
apparatus and are his followers okay
with this
when some democratic voters said defund
the police
they said no no no no that'll destroy
america even even though
no democrats in power want to defund the
police
almost no democrats in power want to
defund the police now trump on a whim
says defund the military because someone
tweeted mean things about me
and the cultists are mostly silent there
are a few who are angry about it
and we will talk about that on today's
bonus show but the big takeaway here
is that january 20th cannot come soon
enough
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in
cherry ice flavor lucy is affordable
it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store shipping is always free
you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020.
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical